hello everyone and welcome to Simply
learns YouTube channel the world is
running towards a new dawn with AI
leading at the Forefront of Innovations
if you are curious about what kind of AI
jobs exist in the IT world today and how
much do skilled AI professionals make in
salary then this video is just the right
one for you without any further Ado
let's get started in a world fueled by
Innovation and driven by techn techology
there exists a breed of professionals
who have the power to shape the future
they are the AI Engineers The Architects
of intelligence the ones who bridge the
gap between human potential and machines
capability but have you ever wondered
what lies behind the curtain of their
remarkable work today we embark on a
journey to unravel the mysteries of the
AI Engineers world the demand for AI
Engineers has skyrocketed companies
across various sectors are competing to
secure these exception talents and and
they are willing to offer High salary
packages according to Industry reports
the salaries of AI Engineers have been
on a remarkable upward trajectory with
their expertise in high demand AI
Engineers have become one of the most
sought out after professions in the job
market in this video we will cover
topics like the rising demand for AI
Engineers factors affecting AI Engineers
salary skills required for AI Engineers
salary of AI engineers and companies
hiring for AI engineers now before
moving forward let me ask you a quick
question what is the term used to
describe an AI systems ability to learn
and improve the experience without being
explicitly
programmed option A is machine learning
option b is artificial neural network
option C is reinforcement learning and
option D is deep learning now you can
pause this video and answer in the
comment section below so let's move on
to the first topic which is the rising
demand for AI Engineers the need for AI
Engineers is growing rapidly because of
the increasing popularity of artificial
intelligence we see AI in things like
cars that can drive themselves and
digital assistants like Ci Alexa and
Google Assistant which can understand
and respond to human voice commands
providing helpful information and
Performing tasks AI is becoming more and
more common in our everyday lives and
that's why there is a big demand for AI
Engineers these Engineers have a special
mix of knowledge about technology and
skills for solving problems with their
expertise they can create new and
creative AI Solutions so in a nutshell
the rising demand for AI Engineers is a
result of transformative impact of AI on
various Industries now let's understand
the factors affecting AI engineer
salary so first is experience AI
Engineers with several years of hands-on
experience in developing AI algorithms
and systems command higher salaries due
to their expertise and track record of
successful projects Junior AI Engineers
while earning relatively less have
opportunities for growth and skill
development now second is location the
geographical location plays a
significant role in determining a
engineer salaries Tech hubs such as
Silicon Valley New York City and London
tend to offer higher salaries due to the
concentration of AI driven companies and
fierce competition for talent third is
educational background the educational
background of AA Engineers can greatly
impact their salaries AA Engineers who
have advanced degrees tend to earn
higher salaries employers recognize the
expertise and in-depth understanding and
are willing to offer higher compensation
to attract and retain these highly
qualified professionals so this was
about factors affecting AI engineer
salary now let's understand about the
skills required for AI engineer to
become an AI engineer certain skills are
essential firstly Proficiency in
programming languages such as python R
Java Scala typescript and C++ is crucial
these languages are commonly used in AI
development and allow Engineers to
implement and optimize AI algorithms
effectively AI engineer should possess
expertise in data handling and Analysis
they should be skilled in collecting
cleaning and manipulating large data
sets to train AI models accurately in
terms of machine learning AI Engineers
need a comprehensive understanding of
machine learning algorithms neural
networks and deep understanding of
Frameworks like tensor flow or pych a
strong Foundation of mathematics is
necessary knowledge of probability
statistics calculus and linear algebra
is vital for AI engenius these
mathematical Concepts underpin the
algorithms and models used in AI systems
and understanding them is essential for
building accurate and efficient AI
models now coming to the exciting part
of this video that is salary of AI
engineer artificial intelligence
engineer in the United States can expect
to earn salaries within a range of
$18,000 to
$162,000 with a median salary of
$135,000 these figures reflect the
competitive salary packages offered to
Professionals in this field the salary
range takes into account various factors
including experience location industry
and the specific company in India the
salary range for a Engineers with less
than 1 year to 6 years of experience is
between 3 lakhs to 22 lakhs the average
annual salary for AI engineers in this
range is 7.8 lakhs so this was about the
salary packages of air Engineers now
let's discuss some companies hiring for
a Engineers several prominent companies
are effectively hiring for a Engineers
to fuel their technological advancements
and Innovation these companies recognize
the importance of artificial
intelligence in driving their business
strategies some notable companies hiring
for AI Engineers include so first is
Amazon second is NVIDIA and third is
Microsoft so let's discuss about these
Amazon with 13% of open AI jobs on glass
store Amazon has been at the Forefront
of a integration across its various
products and services they prioritize AI
Engineers to develop cutting Ed
Solutions and enhance customer
experiences second is NVIDIA Nvidia
holds 6% of open AI jobs on Glass St
enhancing their commitment to AI
research and development they focus on
creating Advanced Hardware and software
solutions to enable AI driven
Technologies in Industries like gaming
autonomous vehicles and data centers
Microsoft a technology giant possesses
4% of open AI jobs on Glass St they
heavily invest in AI research and
development working on projects like
natural language processing computer
vision and machine learning to empower
businesses and consumers with AI driven
solution
IBM IBM has been a significant player in
the AI space for years offering various
AI powered services and products they
continue to hire AI Engineers to expand
their capabilities in areas like Watson
AI cloud computing and data analytics
Accenture as a global Professional
Service Company leverages AI to
transform businesses across various
Industries they hire a Engineers to
develop and Implement AI strategies
focusing on areas such as intelligent
automation data analysis and AI driven
customer
experiences at number six we have
Facebook Facebook a leading social media
platform actively recruits air Engineers
to enhance their air driven features
including content recommendation systems
facial recognition and natural language
processing so these were the companies
hiring for air Engineers along with this
there are many more companies that are
actively hiring for a
Engineers ultimately pursuing a career
as an a engineer offers not only
attractive salaries but also the chance
to make a significant impact in a
rapidly advancing field as AI continues
to shape the future the expertise and
contributions of a Engineers will be
instrumental in unlocking new
possibilities this course features
master classes by IBM experts exclusive
hackathon to help you master various
skills like statistics python supervised
learning neuron networks NLP and much
more by covering tools and techniques
like numai pandas and python along with
amazing industry projects so what is
stopping you from building your future
in a ml enroll now the course link is in
the description box machine learning is
transforming Industries and driving
Innovation by enabling systems to learn
from data and make Intelligent Decisions
this has resulted in a skyrocketing
demand for machine learning Engineers
these professionals possess the skills
to develop Advanced algorithms build
predictive models and extract valuable
insights from vast amounts of data the
ER of Big Data States professionals who
can derive insights from vast
information and machine learning
Engineers possess the skills to analyze
complex data sets extract valuable
knowledge and build predictive models
for accurate forecast process Automation
and optimized decision making Industries
such as Healthcare Finance e-commerce
and autonomous vehicles heavily rely on
machine learning to enhance processes
and drive goal as businesses
increasingly recognize the power of data
driven insights the demand for skilled
machine learning Engineers continues to
search the are instrumental in realizing
the potential of machine learning to
optimize operations improve efficiency
and gain a Competitive Edge with the
market value of machine learning
expected to grow exponentially now is
the time to enter into the field of
machine learning and become an ml
engineer who are at the Forefront of
technological advancement and Bing
lucrative career opportunities in this
Dynamic field that opens doors to a
world of endless possibilities and
Promises of fulfilling and impactful
career on that note hello everyone
welcome to Simply learn today we will
explore a profession that has WI wied a
huge surge in demand in recent years
which is going to be the next big thing
in the future can you guess which
profession we talking about well you got
it right that's machine learning
engineer having said that if you want to
Embark your career as an ml engineer
then our postgraduate program in& ml can
be the right option for you this amml
postgraduate program by simply learn in
collaboration with PUO University covers
a wide range of topics and provides
hands-on experience in developing Ai and
machine learning solutions for
professionals who want to upgrade their
skills and P to a career in the field of
AI and machine learning this course
features master classes by Purdue
faculty and IBM experts exclusive
hackathons to help you master various
skills like statistics python supervised
learning neural networks NLP and much
more by covering tools and techniques
like numai pandas python scipi along
with amazing industry projects so what
is stopping you from building your
future in& ml enroll now course link is
added in the description box below make
sure to check that out without any
further Ado let's let's get started meet
John who has been working as a software
developer in the IT industry for over 5
years now John has been hearing a lot
about machine learning lately and how it
has been revolutionizing the tech
industry he wonders whether learning
machine learning would be worth it and
that's when his colleague Harry helps
him out hey harry I've been reading a
lot about machine learning engineering
lately what are your thoughts absolutely
machine learning is booming right now
really quite intriguing but how can I
become an ml engineer well with the
right skill set you can my friend
possibilities are and less wow that's
impressive looks like machine learning
can be a rewarding career with great
opportunities and lucrative salaries
absolutely John so let me tell you more
about the working aspects of machine
learning engineer in detail we'll start
this tutorial with a quick introduction
to who ml engineer is and next we'll
understand what exactly does a machine
learning engineer do next we'll dive
into the roles and responsibilities of a
machine learning engineer after that
we'll discuss some of the most important
skills that an ml engineer should
possess and finally we'll talk talk
about the salary and job prospects of a
machine learning engineer so firstly who
is a machine learning engineer a machine
learning engineer is a skilled
professional who combines expertise in
programming mathematics and machine
learning to develop and deploy
intelligent systems that can learn from
data and make accurate predictions or
decisions the role of a machine learning
engineer involves working with large
data sets pre-processing and cleaning
the data selecting appropriate machine
learning algorithms and training models
using this data they often collaborate
with data scientist and domain experts
like software Engineers to integrate
machine learning Solutions into
production environments for optimizing
and fine-tuning models for accuracy and
efficiency as well as evaluating their
performance and finally they perform a
thorough effective data exploration and
visualization techniques in order to
contribute for better understanding of
the data and identifying patterns making
informed decisions throughout the
machine learning pipelines so what are
the roles and responsibilities of a
machine learning engineer firstly
problem understanding and solution
design machine learning Engineers work
closely with stakeholders domain experts
to understand the business problem or
objective that machine learning can
address they analyze requirements
identify suitable data sources and
propose machine learning based Solutions
this involves translating business
problems into technical specifications
defining measurable goals and designing
the overall architecture of the machine
Learning System data preparation and
Analysis machine learning Engineers need
to have a deep understanding of the data
they're working with this involves
cleaning pre-processing and transforming
raw data into a format suitable for
training and evaluating ml models
exploratory data analysis techniques are
often used to gain insights and
understand the underlying patterns and
relationships within the data model
development and evaluation ml Engineers
are responsible for developing training
and fine-tuning machine learning models
this involves selecting the appropriate
algorithms architectures and techniques
based on the problems at hand you will
need to implement and experiment with
different models such as decision trees
neural networks support Vector machines
and much more and finally monitoring
maintenance and iterative Improvement
after deployment ml Engineers monitor
the performance of deployed models and
address any sort of issues that arise
they design and Implement monitoring
systems to track model performance
detect any kind of anomalies and
identify data drift or concept drift
regular model maintenance is necessary
to retrain and refine models using new
data to maintain accuracy and
adaptability so these are some of the
day-to-day roles and responsibilities of
an ml engineer well let us not talk
about the skill set that a ml engineer
should possess firstly they should have
a strong knowledge on programming tools
now strong programming skills are
essential for machine learning Engineers
programming languages like R which is a
free software environment for
statistical Computing and Graphics can
surely help but mainly they use python
python is widely used in the machine
learning community due to your
Simplicity extensive libraries and
strong ecosystem so you need to
familiarize yourself with python
fundamentals data manipulation libraries
like numai and pandas and machine
learning Frameworks such as tensorflow
pyo and psychic learn also familiarize
yourself with programming Concepts data
structures and algorithms and
additionally knowledge of other
languages like R and Java can be
beneficial secondly machine learning and
deep learning Concepts ml Engineers
should have a deep understanding of
various machine learning algorithms
including supervised learning
unsupervised learning and reinforcement
learning familiarize yourself with
Concepts like KNN linear regression
decision trees support Vector missions
neural networks Ensemble methods and
much more not just that furthermore ml
Engineers need a solid foundation in
mathematics and statistics this includes
knowledge of linear algebra calculus
probability Theory and statistical
analysis understanding these Concepts is
crucial for Designing and implementing
machine learning algorithms now in
addition to these technical skills
machine learning Engineers should also
possess strong analytical and soft
skills to excel in their roles they need
to think critically and out of the box
to understand problems break them down
into manageable components and develop
appropriate machine learning solutions
they should be able to analyze data
identify patterns and make informed
decisions based on the results and
finally communication skills now
effective communication is crucial for
machine learning Engineers they need to
explain complex technical Concepts to
non-technical stakeholders as well while
collaborating with cross functional
teams and present their findings and
recommendations strong written and
verbal communication skills will surely
help convey information clearly and
concisely which not only enhance their
professional growth but also contribute
to their overall effectiveness as a
machine learning engineer with all that
having said let us now discuss some of
the salary and job prospects of a
machine learning engineer now the salary
for machine learning engineer can vary
significantly based on V various factors
in United States of America machine
learning Engineers are in high demand
particularly in technology hubs like
Silicon Valley in California and Tech
hubs like New York according to a report
by glass door the average salary of a
professional ml engineer is around
$19,000 per year now salaries in the US
tend to be higher due to the cost of
living and fierce competition for talent
and entry-level machine learning
Engineers can expect salaries ranging
from 8 $1,000 to $120,000 per year while
mid-level professionals with a few years
of experience can around 120,000 to
$180,000 per year and finally a senior
level or an experienced machine learning
engineer can command salaries exceeding
$200,000 per year as well especially in
Top tire companies or leadership
positions on the other hand in India the
salary range for machine learning
Engineers is relatively lower compared
to the US but it's important to consider
the lower cost of living as well now the
average salary of a machine learning
engineer in India is around 8.5 lakhs
while entry-level machine learning
engineers in India can expect salaries
ranging from 4 lakhs to 8 lakhs per year
and mid-level professionals can ear on
on somewhere between 8 lakhs to 15 lakhs
per year and finally senior level
machine learning Engineers with
extensive experience and expertise can
earn salaries ranging from 15 lakhs to
30 lakhs per year now additionally other
benefits and compensation components
such as bonuses stock options Healthcare
benefits and retirement plan should also
be considered but let's talk about
reality it's crucial to note that these
figures are approximate and can vary
based on various such factors so here
are some of the salary deciding factors
of an machine learning engineer firstly
company and location now the location of
the employing company can impact a
machine learning engineer salary large
technology companies or organizations
with a strong Focus on& ml tend to offer
competitive compensation packages to
attract top talent additionally the cost
of living in different Geographic areas
can affect salary ranges with salaries
often being higher intake hubs or cities
with a higher cost of living work
experience experience plays a
significant role in determining the
salary of an ml engineer generally
Engineers with more years of experience
tend to command higher salaries this is
because experience indicates a deeper
understanding of machine learning
Concepts techniques and real world
applications which makes experienced
Engineers more valuable to the employers
out there skill set and expertise now
specific skills and expertise possessed
by a machine learning engineer can
impact their salaries as well ml
Engineers proficient and popular
programming languages like python R Java
and Frameworks like tensorflow and py
toch and librar such as psychic learn
are often in high demand and can
negotiate higher salaries additionally
specialized knowledge in areas like deep
learning natural language processing
computer vision can also be valuable and
potentially result in higher
compensation and finally the industry
that you're working on and the current
demand pren now the industry in which an
machine learning engineer Works can
influence their salary as well
industries that heavily rely on machine
learning and AI applications such as
Finance Healthcare e-commerce and
autonomous vehicles offer higher salary
packages to machine learning Engineers
due to the high demand for their
expertise also it's important to note
that these relative importance of these
factors may vary depending on the
specific circumstances and job market
conditions salaries can also be
influenced by economic factors market
demand and individual negotiation skills
overall machine learning engineers in
both us India and the rest of the world
can earn competitive salaries and it's
essential to assess the overall
compensation package growth
opportunities and Company culture when
evaluating job opportunities with the
world advancing towards a more informed
and databased future learning skills
that help us to be relevant in the job
market is crucial one such skill in the
field of data and AI is natural language
processing let us start by understanding
what NLP is natural language processing
or NLP is a branch of artificial
intelligence or AI that deals with
understanding and manipulating human
language it seeks to develop algorithms
and systems that can understand and
process both structured and unstructured
language data to support decision making
processes NP is a field that has been
gaining momentum in recent years thanks
to Advan in machine learning algorithm
and the availability of large data sets
such as social media conversations
customer reviews and medical records NLP
is used in various applications such as
language translation sentiment analysis
text summarization and text generation
if you want to master NLP and become an
expert NLP engineer then you should
enroll an amazing Ai and machine
learning program by CTIC cdme you will
gain skills like machine learning deep
learning re enforcement learning NLP
generative AI prompt engineering chat
GPT and more this Ai and machine
learning boot camp includes live classes
delivered by industry experts Hands-On
Labs industry relevant projects and
master classes by calch instructors so
hurry up what are you waiting for enroll
the course now find the course Link in
the description box so before we move
ahead consider subscribing to Simply
learn and hit the Bell icon to never
miss any updates from us so let's move
ahead by knowing what does NLP include
at its score NLP involves a series of
steps number one is pre-processing the
first step in NLP is to prepare the
language data for analysis this involves
activities such as cleaning tokenization
and normalization of the text Data step
two involves feature extraction the next
step is to extract relevant features
from the prepared data this involves
identifying keywords stems and parts of
speech tags that are important for the
task at hand step three involves model
training the extracted features are then
used to train a machine learning model
such as neural networks or a support
Vector machine to predict the target
variable and the last step is model
evaluation once the model is trained it
needs to be evaluated to ensure it
performs well on new data now let's move
ahead by knowing NLP job roles and
responsibil ities several job roles that
involves NLP and each role is focused on
different aspects of NLP here are some
most common NLP job roles the number one
is NLP engineer this role involves
developing and implementing NLP
Solutions including building machine
learning models designing pipelines and
developing apis NLP Engineers typically
have a background in engineering or
computer science and have knowledge of
machine learning algorithms software
development and data structures the next
we have is text analytics specialist
this role involves analyzing large
amount of Text data to extract useful
information text analytics Specialists
typically have a background in data
analysis statistics and machine learning
and they use NLP tools and techniques to
process and analyze text Data language
model engineer this role involves
developing and improving natural
language processing models such as
language models and and machine
translation models language model
Engineers typically have a background in
computer science machine learning and
natural language processing on number
four we have NLP researcher this role
involves conducting Research into new
NLP methods and techniques NLP
researchers typically have a background
in computer science machine learning and
natural language processing and they
publish their research in various
academic journals and conferences and
the most awaited let's start with salary
of NLP Engineers let us now discuss the
salary of NLP engineers in India and USA
for the sake of better understanding we
will split up the salary ranges based on
the experience level of a professional
so let's start with entry-level NLP
engineers in India the salary ranges
from 2.5 million rupees to 5 million
rupees however in us the salary ranges
between $60,000 to $90,000 per year
enter level NLP Engineers typically have
background in computer science
engineering or a related field and have
some experience with NLP but may not
have yet worked on large scale
Enterprise projects moving towards
midlevel NLP Engineers these Engineers
earn 5 million to 8 million rupees per
year however in United States they earn
between $90,000 to
$120,000 per year midlevel NLP Engineers
have few years of experience working on
NLP projects and typically comfortable
working on both Technical and business
related aspects of NLP projects they may
have some leadership responsibilities
and are often responsible for ensuring
that NLP projects are completed on time
and to spec next we have a senior level
NLP Engineers these Engineers earn up to
8 million rupees to 15 million rupees in
India per year however in United States
they earn between
$120,000
$265,000 per year senior level NLP
Engineers have extensive experience
working on Enterprise level NLP projects
and are often considered authorities in
NLP Technologies methods and tools they
may serve as subject matter experts lead
teams of Engineers and other NLP
professionals and be responsible for
ensuring the long-term success of NLP
project amops is the next evolution of
operations it's a new way approaching
your day-to-day operations making it
much easier to manage and more efficient
to learn mlops is about streamlining
your organization processes automating
those processes and ensuring that you
are using the right tools correctly it's
about taking the time to understand your
team's need and making them happen
before we move on to the what amops is
if you are an expiring AIML engineer
then there is no better time to train
yourself and the exciting field of
machine learning if you are looking for
a course that covers everything from the
scratch to Advanced Techniques like
machine learning algorithm development
and unsupervised learning look no
further than our Caltech in partnership
with IBM this AIML boot cam in
collaboration with ctech will help you
advance your career as an AIML
specialist this AIML boot cam includes
live classes delivered by industry
relevant projects and master classes by
celtech professors key features of this
amazing learning course include earn up
to 22 cus from ctech ctme online
convocation by Kelch ctme program
director simply learns career service
help you to get notice by top hiring
companies on a boot camp certificate
from CC ctma industry relevant capson
project in three domains CCH ctm Circle
membership 25 plus Hands-On projects
across vertical integrated Labs so why
join now seats are filling fast find the
course link from the description box
below so without any further Ado let's
get started so what is an mlops engineer
mlops and devops are both set of
practices that aims to improve the
development and deployment of software
and machine learning models both
practices aims to enhance efficiency
collaboration and reliability in their
perspective domains amops Engineers are
people who build maintain and optimize
machine learning Solutions amops
Engineers have a wide range of skills
including knowledge of data science
software engineering and domain
expertise in the industry in which they
work moving forward let's see some amops
engineer skills amops Engineers are the
bridge between machine learning
operations they ensure the machine
learning models are being being deployed
and updated correctly not causing any
problem the technical skills you need to
be an amops engineer are data science
statical modeling python or R
programming machine learning SQL Linux
and uni cell scripting they also need to
interpret the results of the models
which means they need to be able read
data on a fundamental level and
understand how it relases to the problem
being solved by the model mlops need to
have the following skills like having
experience working in an agile
environment be a problem solver and a
quick learner understand the importance
of continuous learning and personal
development demonstrate knowledge of at
least one programming language like
python or Java so moving forward let's
see mlops engineer salary in the ever
evolving landscape of technology and its
impact on the job market one career path
is stand out with remarkable potential
or growth amops engineer so according to
Bureau of Labor Statistics by 2024 there
will be 20% increas in the job for amops
engineers Which is higher than an
average for all careers in the field so
salary in the US is if you're looking to
make a career change or want to make
more money amops Engineers might be the
right choice for you top companies like
Dell Boeing Nvidia are many more hiring
mlops in here in the US according to
glass door the national average salary
for amops engineering is
$125,000 annually in US and the salaries
in India the demand for amops engineer
in India has caught the attention of
major industry players with round
companies like Bosch IBM Nvidia and many
others actively seeking to add these
professional to their teams according to
glassor the national average salary for
mlops engineer is 12 lakh perm in India
in conclusion embracing mlops is not
just a choice it's a strategic decision
that can reshape how an organization
approaches machine learning so
accelerate your career in a ml with our
comprehensive postgraduate program in
AIML boost your career with this AIML
course delivered in collaboration with
part University and IBM learn in demand
skills such as machine learning deep
learning NLP computer vision
reinforcement learning generative AI
prompt learning chity and many mo you
will receive a prestigious certificate
and ask me anything session by MV so why
wait join now seats are feeling fast
this course link is in the description
box
below staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corpor ations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nert up and get certified
click
here